[موسيقى]
بالنسبة لأولئك الذين يحبون السفر ،
ننتظر اللقاحات
لإعادة فتح الحدود والاستقرار الذي سيأتي عاجلاً
لبعض البلدان وللأسف لاحقًا بالنسبة
للآخرين ،
ولكن بينما ننتظر نحلم بأنك تخطط ، نأمل
في فتح العالم الذي تم
إغلاقه  بالنسبة لنا ، هذه هي الوجهات التي
يسعدنا زيارتها
بمجرد أن تصبح آمنة هنا ، تسافر cnn في
21 مكانًا للذهاب في عام 2021 وما بعد
رؤية القارة السابعة هي واحدة
من أكبر أحلام السفر هناك
الآن تخيل أن هذه القمم البيضاء الساطعة
تسير لفترة وجيزة  الظلام
خلال الكسوف الشمسي الذي يأتي في
ديسمبر
، تقدم ثاني أكبر دولة في العالم
عجائب برية حقًا ،
لكننا أيضًا
مهووسون بمشهد الطعام الذي لم يتم تقديره بشكل كبير
، حيث كانت مناطق الجذب السياحي في حرب النجوم في ديزني
بالكاد مفتوحة في عام عندما ضرب الوباء ،
نريد العودة إلى المجرة.  شاهد حتى
الآن
التجديدات الرئيسية في Epcot وشاهد
كيف تستمر ديزني لاند هونغ كونغ في التوسع في
إقامة معرضها العالمي الأول في
الشرق الأوسط هذا العام
dub  تستعرض ai أيضًا
متحفها الجديد الطموح للمستقبل
لأولئك الذين يعانون من الجوع من العجائب القديمة ،
تجد 5000 عام من التاريخ
مليئًا بالمتحف المصري الكبير
، لقد مرت 20 عامًا على صنعه ومن
المقرر افتتاحه
هذا العام ما هو الأفضل  لست
متأكدًا
من صعوبة اختيار لا ، ربما لا ، أنا
حقًا أحب المعجنات
كل الأشياء الرائعة التي جذبت 90
مليون زائر سنويًا إلى فرنسا
قبل الوباء ، ما زالوا ينتظروننا
الخبز والجبن والمعجنات التي نحتاجها
الحانات الصغيرة والحانات الصغيرة بحاجة إلينا
بعد ذلك  المتنزهات الوطنية والشواطئ الجميلة
غانا في منتصف
نهضة الفنون
والأزياء ويمكننا جميعًا استخدام القليل من
الإلهام في هذا القسم
مع اقتصاد يعتمد على السياحة ،
وعملت اليونان بجد طوال الصيف لتكييف
فنادقها الخاصة بفحص الحدود
وإرشادات السلامة العامة من أجل
الوباء
ولكن سماءه الزرقاء المثالية لا تحتاج
إلى مساعدة للبقاء نقيًا ،
والمعروف أيضًا باسم جزيرة التوابل ،
تشتهر غرينادا بثقافتها
الغنية وشخصيتها.  يشتهر زوار جزر هاواي بـ 40 من
الشواطئ ذات الرمال البيضاء
والغابات الاستوائية المطيرة ،
وسرعان ما
يتعلمون أن جمالها المهيب
لا يضاهيه سوى قوتها الروحية
التي طغى عليها الوباء في الربيع الماضي ، وقد
سطعت مرونة إيطاليا
المشرقة ، ومن المرجح أن يستغرق الأمر
سنوات للحصول على عشرات الملايين.  عودة السائحين سنويًا
، قد يقدم عدد أقل من الحشود
سببًا إضافيًا للعودة
بمجرد أن يكون آمنًا ،
نأمل أن يجتمع العالم معًا لغرض أكثر إشراقًا في شهر
يوليو
للاحتفال بأولمبياد طوكيو المؤجلة
كما لو لم يكن هناك ما يكفي
لتحب جزر المالديف.  عدد كبير من
المنتجعات
الجديدة وستكون أول دولة في
العالم تقدم برنامج ولاء ،
لذا اذهب مرة أخرى ثم اذهب مرة أخرى.
الذكرى السنوية الـ500 لتأسيس
مدينة المكسيك
دائمًا بالقرب من أعلى قوائم دلو المسافر ، أصبحت
نيوزيلندا الآن مرغوبة أكثر بالنسبة إلى هافين
أبقت g حدودها مغلقة
وحالات منخفضة خلال الوباء
العام الماضي وجد سكان نيويورك حبًا متجددًا
للعروض الخارجية للمدينة ،
حدائق الممرات المائية ونزهات الأرصفة ،
كل ذلك وأكثر في انتظار السياح عندما
يكونون مستعدين للعودة ،
ومن المحتمل أن يعني وصولهم إلى سنغافورة
الوصول  في أفضل مطار في العالم ،
تهيئ هذه المرحلة لرحلة مذهلة
لا تُنسى
[الموسيقى]
تشتهر إسبانيا بحشود
السائحين نظرًا لمناظرها المعمارية
المذهلة وفن الطهي المذهل
، فقد تختفي الحشود لفترة من الوقت
ولكن الجمال لا يزال موجودًا
شجعت كل ركن من أركان تايلاند
السياحة المحلية بشكل كبير هذا العام
، وقد نجح هذا الأمر في أن المطاعم
والفنادق لا تزال تعمل بشكل
جيد وأنهم ينتظرون
عودة الزوار الدوليين
بسبب خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد الأوروبي ،
فقد انخفضت قيمة الجنيه البريطاني
مما جعل ما كان يومًا باهظًا
وجهة
لقضاء الإجازة بأسعار معقولة أكثر قليلاً
وأخيراً باعتبارها ثاني أصغر دولة في أمريكا الجنوبية
لا تحظى أوروجواي بالاهتمام الذي يحظى
به جيرانها الأكبر ، لكن المسافرين الحقيقيين
يعرفون أن ذلك غالبًا ما يعني أن
الجوهرة تنتظر إلقاء نظرة فاحصة